hi my name is James honey I'm studying
physics our Sultan grammar school I was
wondering have you had many people
trying to contradict your theory that
one you're the Nobel Prize and also have
you ever used the prize to pick up girls
well hi James so actually it's not my
theory but my measurements that got a
prize for us so no I don't think anybody
has seriously tried to contradict the
measurements there are a few people who
don't think we did it right but there
are only a few such people so the answer
to your second question is do i use the
price to pick up girls well the closest
I've got was to meet the queen of Sweden
when the prize was given and that was a
lovely event